now shifting gears to the swamp in d.c
where senator lindsey graham
standing up to the biden open borders
amnesty agenda he's saying these efforts
now
to sneak amnesty and amnesty package
into the so-called
human infrastructure package is the
dumbest idea in the history of the
senate
and that's not all because senator
graham is also standing up for
chick-fil-a
after apparent efforts to ban it from
notre dame he joins us now
south carolina senator lindsey graham uh
okay uh
you you you are with me because you and
i have had many discussions and even
years back debates over the borders yeah
secure the border first
and that's not happened we now have
nearly 200 000 people a month
the answer is simple in my mind right
yeah it is too so i've been dealing with
illegal immigration for 15 years and
what have i learned
if you have policies that incentivize
illegal immigration you'll get more of
it
if policies that deter legal immigration
you'll get less
the dumbest idea in all of washington
would be to grant amnesty in an
infrastructure bill
without first securing the border you
would have an invasion beyond what you
have today
if we legalized a hundred thousand
people or a million people in the
infrastructure bill
there would be a run on our border
because everybody would get the message
they're legalizing people in america
let's go and let's go now
you have to secure the border before you
grant one person
legal status if you don't you will lose
control
of of america of our sovereignty well
it's amnesty behind all of this you've
tried to be a part of these bipartisan
discussions
uh democrats though in many ways i see
them saying oh well we got a bipartisan
bill on
human infrastructure and then they'll
use reconciliation to get everything
else they want are you gonna allow that
to happen
well so i said a couple of days ago that
if they put amnesty
into three and a half trillion dollar
infrastructure bill that's got nothing
to do with infrastructure it's big
government hired texas
but if they put amnesty in that bill i
would
try to deny them a quorum to pass that
bill it's a 50 50 senate
and the vice president doesn't count
toward a quorum so a lot of people have
pushed back to me to my republican
colleagues what are we going to do if
they load up the three and a half tree
israeli five trillion
infrastructure bill with melon boating
and with amnesty
what is our response if you don't like
my idea
come up with one of your own if we don't
fight back as hard as we can
they're destroying the senate as i speak
they're going to lead to an illegal
immigrant invasion like we've never seen
in the history of the country
so my idea is do anything and everything
possible to stop this
before it happens let the democrats know
that if you pat
if you put illegal legalizing
illegal immigrants in the reconciliation
bill
then we as republicans will use
everything available to us
including denying unicorn everybody that
watches this show
probably knows by now i don't support
boycotts never have
and i'm never going to or cancel culture
but i do support boycotts and i like
what you said about chick-fil-a
and i urge everybody i love chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a i love it
it's absolutely amazing so okay they
want to hurt chick-fil-a
um i'm going to support chick-fil-a just
because i like it
amen thoughts so no notre dame is
notre dame's a great university you had
a handful of notre dame students and
faculty
petitioning the university not to allow
chick-fil-a on campus
well i spoke up it's the number one fast
food
company in america it's good food good
service at a reasonable price and the
kathy family
are religious people and they dare act
on their religion so here's my statement
to the
faculty and students at notre dame you
don't have the right to deny somebody to
do business because they have sincerely
religiously held beliefs that's very bad
and very dangerous for america
so we got to speak up sean if they put
amnesty in the infrastructure bill
if you don't like my ideas republican
you better come up with one of your own
because we'll surrender
and just be run over and i'm not going
to let that happen when you
when a company like chick-fil-a is
attacked because they want to act on
their faith
and we don't stand behind them then
somebody will come after our faith
that's well said by the way i will go to
chick-fil-a but if the line is like it
usually is
down the block around the corner i'm not
going to wait
oh i'm only going in if it's a short
line
anyway but i do believe in boycotts
all right senator thank you